[Applause]
cardi b
and megan the stallion defied
expectations by making
wap ready for prime time
and maybe grammy's host trevor noah put
it best
oh guys guys wait wait i just realized
something
this is a dream this is a dream that
i've had to be in bed
with cardi b and then my grandmother
comes in and whips our asses for having
our shoes on in the bed the performance
had rave reviews on social media and
post malone was all of us who are
witnessing the magic
megan performed two of her other hit
songs body and savage
if you know me you have to know that
ever since i was little i was like you
know what one day i'mma grow up and i'm
gonna be like the rap beyonce
the 26 year old singer had quite a night
taking home trophies for best new artist
[Music]
and her collab with beyonce the savage
remix won her best
rap performance i made it through and
now i'm here
i've i've already won one grammy megan
won that award before the broadcast
began
and she told et about her magical
experience working with queen bee
hey um for two girls from houston two
girls grew up with a dream
and now you have this song that like
when it when that remix hit
it exploded exploded it was like the
world
shifted or something everybody will
always ask me in every interview i ever
did who do you want to do a song with
what would you what would be your dream
feature and i'll be like beyonce beyonce
every interview
i spoke that into existence so when i
finally got it i was like
y'all i got a song to be honest i had to
call my grandma we was both crying
how did y'all keep it a secret um
literally
it happened like i heard the song and
then it came out the next day
so i didn't even have to hold it for a
long time really
[Music]